ieur
président
[Musique]
la séance est
ouverte le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le Procé
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage chers
collègues madame la Première ministre
Mames et messieurs les ministres le
plaisir de saluer dans la tribune
d'honneur une délégation de 5 sénateurs
conduite par
pierolo président du Sénat de la
République du Congo ils sont accompagnés
par nos collègues Guillaume chevrolier
président de groupe d'amitié France
Afrique centrale et Stéphane demilli
président délégué pour le Congo au sein
de ce groupe et par Son Excellence
Monsieur rodolp Adada ambassadeur de la
République du Congo en France nous
venons d'avoir un entretien
particulièrement dense avec le président
de goollo et sa délégation sur nos
relations bilatéral mais aussi sur les
récentes évolutions en Afrique nous
avons signé un protocole de coopération
parlementaire qui contribuera à enrichir
les liens entre nos assemblées dans les
prochaines années en particulier sur le
volet de la
Décentralisation et des relations de
l'État avec les collectivités locales
qui intéressent particulièrement
nos partenaires congolais le Sénat
français entretient de longues dates
d'excellentes relations avec le Sénat de
la République du Congo ces rapports de
confiance et d'amitié sont à l'image du
partenariat étroit qui unit nos deux
pays permettez-moi mes chers collègues
de souhaiter en votre nom à tous à nos
homologues du Sénat congolais la plus
cordiale bienvenue ainsi qu'un excellent
et fructueux
séjour
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur public Sénat
et sur notre site chacun sera attentif
au cours de nos échanges au respect des
uns et des autres et au respect du temps
de parole je vais donner la parole
immédiatement à madame la Présidente
Marie SCER pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Madame la premierre
ministre à qui profite le crime la
coalition d'opposition que tout oppose à
recalé le projet de loi immigration quel
que soient nos convictions doit-on se
réjouir de la multiplication de ces
blocages institutionnels le 493
répétition une motion de rejet
sommes-nous face à une crise politique
simplement conjoncturelle en partie nous
assistons sans doute aux limite du en
même temps promu par l'exécutif car nous
voyons nous voyons bien que certains
groupes parlementaires rejette la
culture du compromis et préfère les cûps
politiques au débat mais au fond le RD
ce souhaite que l'on s'interroge
davantage sur nos institutions qui
globalement semblent marquer le pas et
traverser une crise assez profonde au
point qu'ici au Sénat nous avons presque
l'impression de vivre un système
monocaméral à défaut de se construire au
Palais Bourbon le dialogue se tente au
Palais du Luxembourg bien entendu en
tant que sénateur on peut se réjouir
d'un Sénat mise en lumière comme chambre
de modération pourvu toutefois que le
compromis y trouve aussi sa place avec
ouverture et sincérité sur des sujets
fondamentaux pour nos concitoyens la CMP
sur le projet de loi immigration
pourrait avoir ainsi valeur de test
cependant profondément attaché au
bicamérisme et à la démocratie
représentative socle de notre République
le groupe RDSE souhaite voir au plus
vite émerger une gouvernance plus
apaisée dans cette perspective madame la
Première ministre envisagez-vous des
réflexions sur le fonctionnement des
y compris sur la décentralisation tout
cela dans l'intérêt des Français
merci pour vous répondre à la parole est
à madame la Première ministre vous avez
la parole madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la Présidente Marie
scarer lundi à l'Assemblée nationale la
nup et l'extrême droite se sont alliés
pour empêcher le débat sur le projet de
loi
immigration comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le
dire cette alliance cette alliance
baroque est irresponsable
elle s'est faite au mépris du travail
parlementaire au mépris des attentes des
Français madame la Présidente Marie
scarer je connais l'attitude
constructive de votre groupe tout au
long de la discussion du texte au Sénat
le groupe RDSE et le plus ancien groupe
parlementaire de notre République je
sais son attachement au débat et au
pluralisme je sais également votre
volonté de trouver des solutions
concrètes et efficaces pour les Français
notamment face au défis migratoirees
cette volonté c'est aussi la mienne
c'est aussi celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald d'Anin et de tout mon
gouvernement no concitoyens attendent
des solutions et des réponses nos forces
de l'ordre nous demandent des moyens
d'action plus efficaces
nous devons éloigner plus facilement les
personnes en situation irrégulière et
mieux intégrer cell que nous accueillons
c'est l'objectif que poursuit mon
gouvernement c'est je n'en doute pas
l'état d'esprit qui guidera les travaux
de la commission mixte paritaire qui se
tiendra lundi c'est la condition pour
qu'un texte puisse être adopté au Sénat
comme à l'Assemblée nationale la
condition pour apporter les réponses
attend par nos concitoyens je remercie
madame la
Présidente président
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républiain monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre c'est un
fiasco depuis 2022 le président de la
République subit une crise
institutionnelle vous venez d'y ajouter
une crise politique majeure et inédite
en jouant sur les peurs le président de
la République attise les braises d'un
pays déjà incandescent
oui c'est irresponsable votre Ministre
aux déclaration à géométrie variable a
pris sur lui l'entière charge du projet
de loi immigration il a échoué au
travers de son échec vous avez échoué et
au travers de votre échec c'est le
président de la République qui a échoué
à vouloir tromper tout le monde vous
n'avez convaincu personne vous avez
provoqué cette situation c'est à vous de
nous en sortir désormais mais puisque
vous écartez un nouvel article 49 ale à
3 quelle sera l'ampleur de la
capitulation de la majorité
présidentielle en commission mixte
paritaire quelle sera le prix du
renoncement aux valeurs républicaines la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État la
fin de la régularisation des
travailleurs dans les métiers en
tenstion l'instauration d'une préférence
nationale madame la Première ministre il
est encore temps suivez l'exemple du
président rotillot retirez votre projet
de loi
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Patrick
canner lundi à l'Assemblée nationale vos
collègues députés socialistes ont pris
une décision lourde ils ont choisi de
mêler leur voix à celle de l'extrême
droite pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats au
Parlement ils ont choisi de refuser
d'exercer leur mission de parlementaire
discuter et voter la loi je me souviens
d'un temps où le parti socialiste porta
des combats et des valeurs d'un temps où
il défendait avec force le Parlement le
Parti socialiste était un parti de
gouvernement à l'Assemblée de plus en
plus il s'enferme dans l'obstruction
monsieur le Président
canner je connais la sincérité de vos
convictions je connais votre attachement
à la démocratie parlementaire alors je
vous le demande avec vos collègues
sénateurs socialistes allez-vous laisser
le Parti socialiste se dissoudre au sein
de
l'anupes
allez-vous allez-vous le laisser sans
rien dire devenir un satellite de la
France insoumise et voter avec le
rassemblement national où comptez-vous
sauver l'honneur du Parti socialiste
défendre ce qui fait son histoire et ses
valeurs en attendant avec mon
gouvernement nous ne laisserons jamais
les manœuvres politiciennes l'emporter
les Français attendent des solutions il
demande des mesures fortes face à
l'immigration illégale il souhait que
nous travaillons pour une meilleure
intégration de ceux que nous accueillons
avec le ministre de l'intérieur c'est ce
que nous sommes déterminés à faire une
commission x paritaire se tiendra lundi
nous sommes résolus à apporter des
réponses à nos concitoyens avec mon
gouvernement nous choisirons toujours la
voix de la responsabilité et le chemin
de l'action je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
caner madame la PR ministre je vous ai
posé une question de fond vous poser de
manière
politicienne vous
connaissez la locution latine bien connu
des juristes nul ne peut se prévaloir de
sa propre
turpitude excusez-moi de vous rappeler
que le 14 novembre ici les sénateurs de
votre groupe majoritaire à quelques
exceptions ont votter le texte de la
droite sénatoriale avec toutes les
suppressions que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure
alors je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir au
nom de mon groupe ne laissez pas vos
députés Renaissance se dissoudre parmi
les députés LR qui se dissou qui se
dissolvent eux-mêmes dans les groupes de
la République de la du rassemblement
national voilà la réalité voilà la
réalité qui est posée madame la Premier
ministre retirez votre
texte la parole est à madame la
Présidente Cécile cuckerman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
kaki monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mes chers collègues le
rejet préalable de votre projet de loi
sur l'immigration lundi à l'Assemblée
nationale est un échec cuisant vous osez
dénoncer l'empêchement du débat alors
que vous avez vous-même coupé cours à
toute discussion des députés à 20
reprises tant sur les retraites que sur
les budgets par les 493 successifs vous
allez aujourd'hui nous opposer qu'en
l'absence d'un tel débat à l'Assemblée
c'est un texte plus dur celui du Sénat
qui devient la base de travail commune
aux deux chambres mais la confusion
madame la Première ministre c'est vous
qui l'avez entretenu en accompagnant ici
le texte de la droite sénatoriale vos
soutiens ici au Sénat ont voté le texte
sénatorial alors que votre groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale l'a profondément
travailler cette incohérence vous la
payz votre réponse à cet échec et à
cette grande confusion
c'est la convocation dans l'urgence
d'une commission mixte paritaire pour
tenter de petits arrangements nous
n'acceptons pas ce coup de force contre
la démocratie cette mise en cause
profonde du Parlement madame la Première
ministre allez-vous renoncer à la
convocation de la commission mixte
paritaire pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente Cécile cuerman
à l'Assemblée nationale
lundi ceux qui
prétendent ceux qui prétendent donner
des leçons de démocratie au gouvernement
ont choisi d'empêcher le débat
parlementaire je réponds à la même
question monsieur le sénateur ce choix
mené de concert avec l'extrême droite
n'a pas entamé notre volonté d'apporter
des réponses aux attentes de nos
concitoyens madame la Présidente Cécile
cuckerman les Français soutiennent notre
texte il demande que nous puissions
expulser plus facilement les étrangers
délinquants ou ceux qui ne respectent
pas les principe républicain il demande
que nous puissions donner plus de
capacité d'action à nos forces de
l'ordre pour lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière il demande que nous
renforcions les sanctions contre les
passeurs contre les marchands de som
meil il demande que nous intégrions
mieux ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir ces objectifs sont ceux de
notre texte nous voulons apporter à nos
concitoyens les solutions qu'ils
attendent rien ne nous fera dévier de
cette ligne une commission mixte
paritaire a été convoqué le débat
parlementaire continue nous souhaitons
parvenir à un accord avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald armanin avec mon
gouvernement notre détermination est
totale je vous remercie madame la
Présidente monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mes chers collègues
ces mêmes français que vous appelez
aujourd'hui à la rescous étaient près de
70 % à rejeter le texte sur les
retraites et vous ne les avez pas écouté
les Français ce n'est pas en même temps
comme ça vous arrange les Français ce
sont aujourd'hui les citoyens de notre
pays qui nous permettent de dire que
nous sommes en République aujourd'hui
vous faites le choix de piétiner le
débat parlementaire en convoquant une
commission mixte paritaire alors même
qu'aucun texte n'a été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale et madame la
Première ministre ayons un discours de
sincérité à l'Assemblée nationale lundi
il y a eu des groupes de gauche il y a
eu plusieurs groupes à droite je vous
rappelle madame la Premier ministre que
les cinq voix qui vous mentent ne sont
pas que le seul fait de la gauche mais
de l'arc républicain présent ici au
Sénat et c'est à ceci que vous devez
travailler pour répondre à l'urgence du
bien vivre des Françaises et des
Français dans notre pays
merci la parole est à notre
collègue Pascal Martin pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outres maires hier l'une de nos
collègues députés vous a interrogé sur
sur la publication imminente d'un décret
très attendu par les 200000 saport
pompiers volontaires en cette période de
Sainte Barbe ce décret met en œuvre
l'article 24 de la loi du 14 avril
dernier de financement rectificative de
la sécurité sociale pour 2023 article
qui accorde au titre de la solidarité
nationale le droit des trimestres de
retraite supplémentaires aux assurés
ayant accompli au moins 10 années
d'engagement continue ou non en qualité
de saportpompier volontaire or dans sa
rédaction actuelle le projet de décret
d'application de cette disposition
législative en limiterait le bénéfice au
seul sapport pompiers volontairees ayant
eu une carrière haché c'est-à-dire ne
bénéficiant pas de l'ensemble des
trimestres de cotisation retraite sur
leur carrière ce qui serait en totale
contradiction avec l'esprit du
législateur et viderait le dispositif de
son contenu puisqu'alors seul 10 % des
bénéficiaires potentiels serait concerné
monsieur le ministre la réponse que vous
avez faite hier à notre collègue député
ne nous a pas complètement rassur assuré
certes vous avez affirmé que le décret
appliquerait la loi strictement vous
nous et nous vous en remercions mais en
même temps vous n'avez pas nier que le
texte en préparation restreindrait
considérablement le dispositif dans ces
conditions monsieur le ministre je vous
le demande très solennellement vous
engagez-vous aujourd'hui à ne pas
limiter l'avantage retraite accordé par
la loi du 14 avril dernier au seul saort
pompiers volontaire ne bénéficiant pas
de l'ensemble des trimestres de
cotisation retraite sur leur carrière je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
haranin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le le sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison un décret est
aujourd'hui en discussion au Conseil
d'État il vise à appliquer les très
nombreuses mesures en tout cas il
termine les très nombreuses mesures que
nous avons pris collectivement d'abord
dans la loi matras je voudrais rappeler
qu'évidemment c'est à l'initiative de la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale et
grâce au députés matras que ces
dispositions extrêmement importantes
pour les sapurs pompiers volontaes é été
tenu et que vous les avez soutenu puis
dans des articles du PLFSS et notamment
vous évoquez dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites pour la première fois des
trimestres supplémentaires pour
reconnaître l'engagement de nos sapeurs
pompiers volontaires le ministre en
charge des sapeurs pompiers que je suis
même si c'est partagé évidemment avec
les dis que vous connaissez bien est
très favorable non seulement à la loi
telle qu'elle a été votée mais à
l'esprit de la loi telle que vous l'avez
présenté et oui je veux redire devant
votre assemblée que malgré le fait qu'il
y a cette discussion au Conseil d'État
ce décret n'est toujours pas publier et
la Direction de la Sécurité sociale qui
est sous l'autorité du ministre des
comptes publiques et de la ministre en
charge des solidarité il y a une
discussion et je veux vous redire que
l'arbitrage de la première ministre
ettant des fait que nous respecterons
bien sûr et bien évidemment
l'intégralité de la loi et l'esprit de
la loi qui a été voté par vous-même le
président de la Fédération nationale des
sa pompiers monsieur Boland m'a saisi je
lui ai répondu et je crois que il a été
rassuré lui pardon de pas l'avoir fait
pour vous j'espère compléter ainsi ma
réponse à la suite de la question posée
hier par une député à l'Assemblée
nationale nous aurons à la sortie du
texte au Conseil d'État des discussions
évidemment avec la Fédération nationale
des saports pompiers je mis eng gage
avec mes collègues du gouvernement sous
l'autorité de la première ministre mais
je veux vous redire ici que les
trimestres supplémentaires pour les
sapurs pompiers volontaire parce qu'ils
donnent du temps ils donnent leur vie et
leur famille évidemment est touché par
leur engagement qui fait honneur à
l'uniforme et à la République sera
respecté le ministre que je suis il
veillera sous l'autorité de la première
ministre Monsieur Pascal
Martin monsieur le ministre merci pour
votre réponse la doctrine opérationnelle
française repose sur la complémentarité
entre les saport pompiers professionnels
les militaires et les saport pompiers
volontaires ces derniers connaissent une
grave crise de de vocation il manque
aujourd'hui 50000 sapport pompiers
volontaires en France cette légitime
demande espéré de depuis 40 ans par ces
femmes et ces hommes qui portent cet
engagement civique remarquable est
attendu par et pour tous les sapports
pompiers volontaires monsieur le
ministre les sapport pompiers
volontaires vous l'urez compris compte
sur vous afin que ce texte soit publié
dans les meilleurs délais dans l'esprit
adopté ici au Sénat il y a quelques mois
merci
beaucoup la parole de notre collègue
Mélanie Vogel pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez essuyer
lundi un échec cuisant cet échec
politique est surtout moral c'est celui
d'une stratégie folle celle d'un
gouvernement qui avait rêvé de mettre
ensemble quelques miettes d'humanité
avec les idées rances les fantasmes
morbides les obsessions xénophobes les
imaginaires racistes de toutes celles et
ceux qui ont fait de la haine des
étrangers la valeur cardinale de leur
projet politique et leur seul et unique
fond de commerce électoral alors depuis
lundi vous pleurnichez et vous accusez
la terre entière une alliance contre
nature se serait formée contre vous vous
nous l'avez déjà dit trois fois on a
compris mais c'est exactement le
contraire qui s'est passé c'est vous qui
avez un jour imaginé dans le
confusionnisme total qui vous
caractérise qu'il était possible de
trouver un équilibre entre la haine et
les valeurs de la République entre
l'égalité et les discriminations entre
l'indignité et l'état de droit entre la
raison et le mensonge et bien cet
équilibre n'existe pas il va vous
falloir choisir alors qu'allez-vous
choisir c'estz une alliance avec la
droite extrême et l'extrême droite comme
vous l'avez fait ici au Sénat conduire
toujours plus à coup de communication
indigne de compromission avec celles et
ceux qui abîment chaque jour la
République la France au bord du gouffre
au point de l'IT jeter ou bien le retour
vers la raison la responsabilité le cap
de la dignité du respect des valeurs
républicaines retireer ce t texte il n'a
aucun avenir digne préférer l'inconfort
d'un instant au déshonneur de toujours
retirer ce texte et accepter de
construire avec celles et ceux qui
portent encore les valeurs de la
République avec celles et ceux qui
regardent le monde tel qu'il est sans
haine sans hypocrisie et sans cynisme un
texte digne rationnel humaniste à la
hauteur de la promesse républicaine un
texte qui traite l'immigration pour ce
qu'elle est ni une menace ni un problème
mais un phénomè
hum on vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
darin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je pense que vous
êtes bien mal placé en leçon de morale
lorsque vous faites une motion de rejet
du groupe des ver voté par le
rassemblement national avec des clin
d'œil tellement grands qu'ils ont été
vus dans toutes les circonscriptions du
P de France madame la sénatrice les
leçons de morale pardon de vous le dire
ell ne rentrent pas pour vous dans la
hauteur de débat que nous avons ce qu'a
fait la dupes et votre groupe voilà
quelques heures à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est que vous avez rejeté non pas le
texte vous le saviez très bien mais le
débat à l'Assemblée nationale vous
saviez pertinemment que ce serait le
texte du Sénat et vous avez poussé ce
cynisme politique pour quelques bons
article dans la presse sans doute à
rejeté par principe le fait que des
mineurs par exemple vous serez plus
jamais dans les centres de rétention
administratif vous avez réussi à rejeter
d'un seul coup tout ce que la gauche en
60 ans n'a jamais fait et que fera le
président de la République alors si vous
vous souhaitiez pas si vous ne
souhaitiez pas que l'ensemble des 150
députés de l'anupes apportte comme nous
l'avons je crois ici montré au Sénat où
majorité opposition et bien sûr
gouvernement ont suprendre des
amendements même si vous ne votiez pas
le texte du groupe communiste du groupe
socialiste et de votre groupe par parce
que vous vouliz refuser le débat
simplement parce que vous vouliz avec
Madame Le Pen faire une alliance contre
nature alors oui et vous pouvez crier
madame c'est la vérité vous vous êtes
allié avec Madame Le Pen et vous vous
êtes levés ensemble ensemble les deux
partis populistes contre les partis de
gouvernement et ça c'est
honteux la parole est au président
Philippe Mouillet pour le group les
républicain madame la premère ministre
monsieur le Président Madame la PR
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues tout
d'abord avant de commencer ma question
je voudrais rassurer le président canner
et lui dire que notre groupe n'a pas
perdu ses valeurs ses convictions elles
sont intactes et c'est parce qu'elles
sont intactes que nous avons retiré le
projet de loi constitutionnel
revenons-en maintenant à ma question qui
ne traite pas de l'immigration mais de
la parole de l'état de la parole de
l'État le 16 juin dernier un séisme du
magéti de 5,8 a frappé le sud de mon
département les Deux Sèvres ainsi que
l'honur de la Charre maritime et le Sud
vandé 3 jours plus tard le gouvernement
était présent par l'intermédiaire du
ministre Christophe Béchu pour remercier
les services de sécurité rassurer les
élus locaux et surtout annoncer aux
habitants qu'une procédure accélérée
pour déclencher lesarêté de catastrophe
naturelle à être mise en place 6 mois
plus tard malgré trois commissions
interministérielles seul 22 communes sur
les 400 concerné ont bénéficié de cette
reconnaissance pire h communes proches
de l'épisotre dont parfois 5 % des
maisons ont été touchées et bien n'ont
pas de nouvelle aujourd'hui de la part
de l'État la commission
interministérielle statue à partir d'un
rapport établi par le Bureau central de
sismologie français or pour certaines
communes ce bureau central n'est
toujours pas passé concrètement en ce
début d'hiver quelle réponse
pouvons-nous apporter aux élus locaux
vis-à-vis de leurs habitants qui ont
leur maison endémagé et pour lequel les
assureurs refusent la prise en charge et
d'une façon générale cette question est
lo conc toutes les situations de
catastrophe naturelle en France les
nombreux territoires qui sont concernés
par les inondations je pense aussi au
zones qui sont imparté par le GR des
argiles quoi répondre au élus locaux
pour répondre la Paro au ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur
Christophe monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Philippe
Mouillet vous avez rappelé la visite que
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire au nom du
gouvernement à la fois pour représenter
la première ministre mais pour
représenter également le ministre de
l'Intérieur en allant sur place au côté
des collectivités devant les maisons
fissurées au milieu de des Mair
directement touché et éprouvé j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que le gouvernement
mettrait tout en œuvre pour procéder à
cette reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle en matière de tremblement de
terre d'après les règles existantes il y
a de critères cumulatifs le premier
c'est qu'un tremblement de terre doit
dépasser 5 sur l'échelle de richterre et
ça a été le cas puisque nous étions
entre 5 1 et 54 mais la totalité des
communes puisque quand vous vous
éloignez de l'épicentre pour certaines
d'entre elles on était avec des niveau
de sismologie qui était inférieur ce qui
explique le besoin à la fois de passage
de ce bureau dont vous avez rappelé
l'existence et d'examen des dossiers au
cas par cas ce qui fait qu'à la minute
où nous parlons nous n'avons
effectivement vos chiffres sont exacts
qu'une trentaine de communes qui
bénéficient de cette reconnaissance au
travers de votre question dans la
continuité des inondations qu'on a connu
au Pas de Calais dans la continuité de
difficultés qu'on a pu connaître dans la
vésubi ou ailleurs on voit bien à quel
point aujourd'hui nous avons atteint une
fin de cycle par rapport à notre système
de fonctionnement sur les catastrophes
naturelles j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur qui a en
responsabilité le fait de les prononcer
et nous avons pu ensemble mesurer un
certain nombre de choses dont nous
allons vous proposer des modifi
depuis le fait qu'on demande à un maire
de faire lui-même la demande alors que
parfois la catastrophe naturelle aboutit
à ce que la mairie soit elle-même frappé
directement par un événement jusqu'au
cas dans lesquels nous devons le
reconnaître puisque quand vous avez des
vents à plus de 200 km outre mer c'est
une catastrophe naturelle et quand c'est
en Bretagne ça n'en est pas on voit bien
et ce sera l'occasion dans les
prochaines semaines du plan national
d'adaptation au changement climatique de
tirer toutes les leçons de ce qui a été
reconnu et de ce qui ne l'a pas été et
de réexaminer la situation de votre
territoire merci pour votre
question monsieur mouiller
oui j'entends votre réponse très
technique moi je vous invite à revenir
dans les de sèves rencontrer les
personnes que vous avez vu et leur
expliquer comment fonctionne la prise en
charge lorsque vous vivez avec des
maisons fissurées et des étis dans dans
les pièces je pense que ça correspond
pas aujourd'hui aux attentes il y a le
décalage entre le discours du jour J et
la réalité aujourd'hui qui de réalité
technique
parole est à notre collègue Michel kouim
Tok pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la Premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Gérald d'armanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outrèes monsieur le
ministre je déplore que la collectivité
française de WIS founa soit toujours
inscrite sur la liste des pays les moins
avancés de l'OCDE
elle ne bénéficie pourtant pas de l'aide
publique au développement notre
éloignement favorise la chaireté
excessive de la vie et l'accumulation
des monopoles provoque tension et crise
sociale comme le Rais comme le récent
blocage de la seule banque de lîle la
BWF j'ai entendu le gouvernement
rappeler la responsabilité de la
collectivité en matière sociale en
préconisant la mise en place d'une
fiscalité directe pour financer les
mesures sociales cependant la réalité
est que sur une population de 12000
habitants seul 2300 personnes sont
salariées fonctionnaires d'État compris
le reste de la population survit
péniblement la location chômage n'existe
pas et le seuil de pauvreté est de 522 €
mensuels le contrat social n'aide que
les personnes âgées les handicapées ou
celles ayant un revenu en dessous du
SMIC qui est de 784 €. aussi depuis le
début de cette année 2023 je propose la
création du RSA à WIS et foutenis j'ai
d'ailleurs présenté un amendement en ce
sens au PLF 2024 qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité par mes collègues sénateurs
que je remercie chaleureusement monsieur
le ministre nous ne sommes pas éligibles
non plus au Pacte des
solidarités qui a pour ambition de
lutter contre la pauvreté pour cette
raison je sollicite la solid ité
nationale pour doter notre contrat
social de 5 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour financer le RSA
comment le gouvernement compte-t-il
répondre à cette demande qui me semble
parfaitement légitime je vous remercie
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outer
monsieur
Darmanin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Sénateur nous connaissons votre
engagement pour VO et Funa ces deux
magnifiques territoires de de la
République et je sais vous battez contre
la pauvreté dans euh ce territoire comme
votre collègue député Michel ce qui a
aussi déposé un amendement comme le
vôtre qui va dans le sens des moyens euh
votés dans le projet lo de finances du
ministre deéconomie et du ministre des
comptes publiques et notamment celui de
900000 € pour aider euh le contrat
social il y a un sujet autour du gage et
je sais que euh grâce au ministre
casenuve nous allons pouvoir retirer le
gage et pouvoir tenir déjà dans le PLF
en effet votre demande d'abondement vous
souhaitez également pouvoir accompagner
socialement pour les personnes qui sont
handicapées les personnes âgées ou les
personnes pauvres un un engagement type
RSA ou contrat social peut-être plus
large nous vous disons notre bien sûr
notre allant pour signer ce tel contrat
avec vous il faut d'abord une
délibération de l'assemblée de Wallis et
fotuna avec une participation de 25 %
des crédits par
le territoire puisque vous connaissez la
non compétence de l'État dans ce sens
mais je veux vous dire que à la demande
de la première ministre nous allons y
travailler y travailler le plus
rapidement possible puisque
indépendamment des autres demandes
d'abondement budgétaire que nous allons
accompagner je pense évidemment aux
questions que vous avez posé autour des
investissements du territoire pour 1,4
million d'euros j'aurai l'occasion au
début d'année prochaine de me rendre à
nouveau dans le Pacifique et sur votre
territoire avec le ministre en charge
des outres mèes pour pouvoir négocier ce
contrat social en lien avec vous-même le
député et l'assemblée de walis et
futounin merci la parole est à notre
collègue Pierre Jean Rochette pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les vers de
Saint-Étienne ont fait la fierté de
toute la France dans les années
70 cette couleur verte cette couleur
verte a été choisie car elle était celle
des magasins du groupe Casino fondé par
Geoffroy Guichard en
1898 aujourd'hui le peuple vert
s'inquiète de l'avenir du groupe Casino
l'entreprise est historiquement
ngérienne et son siège social a toujours
été basé à Saint-Étienne la marque
casino était la première marque
distributeur créée en 1901 elle fait
partie du patrimoine français ces
dernières semaines la situation
financière du groupe s'avère
particulièrement préoccupante pour tous
les employés en attendant l'arrivée de
nouveaux actionnaires en janvier la
vente des hypermarchés et supermarchés
est en cours de discussion dans mon
département le malaise est palpable d'un
côté les personnels des magasins qui
seraient cédés ainsi que les salariés de
la logistique craignent d'être les
perdants de cette restructuration de
l'autre cette opération risque
d'entraîner la suppression de postees au
siège social stéphanois qui emploie 1800
salariés ces craintes sont largement
partagées l'ensemble du groupe ne
risque-t-il pas d'être fragilisé après
une session importante de son parc de
magasins et de ses entrepôts le siège
social pourra-t-il bien être maintenu à
Saint-Étienne est-il indispensable
d'envisager un découpe un découpage
d'une telle ampleur sur les 22000
personnes que l'enseigne Casino emploie
en France 6000 emplois directs pourrai
être menacés c'est pourquoi j'attire
votre attention monsieur le ministre sur
le risque majeur que sera l'effondrement
de ce groupe historique et emblématique
il serait un coup dur pour notre
département mais aussi pour notre pays
monsieur le ministre pour tous les
Ligériens qui sont dans une démarche
tous les Ligériens sont dans une
démarche bienveillante vis-à-vis du
groupe créensski qui uvre à la reprise
de casino mais que peut faire le
gouvernement pour l'assister au mieux et
sauver cette entreprise avez-vous des
échanges avec le repreneur sur l'avenir
du siège social à Saint-Étienne et
comment comptez-vous l'accompagner afin
que le maximum d'emploi soit
préservé pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs mon le sénateur Rochette m'a
posé une question sérieuse à laquelle je
pourrais répondre si vous me le
permettez les salariés du Groupe Casino
monsieur sénateur n'ont pas payé pour
les erreurs stratégiques commises depuis
plusieurs années par la direction du
groupe le groupe a commis des erreurs
stratégiqu il s'est mal positionné il a
eu des prix plus élevés que tous ses
concurrents et évidemment il a été
particulièrement percuté par la crise
inflationniste il accuse donc des pertes
au dernier trimestre pour vous donner un
seul chiffre c'est un demi milliard
d'euros de pertes supplémentaires sur un
trimestre c'est absolument intenable je
suis au côté des salariés j'ai reçu ce
matin l'intersyndical pour faire le
point avec elle je continuerai à les
recevoir et je suis là pour défendre les
intérêts des salariés et garantir le
respect de l'ordre public économique
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire d'abord
éviter la cessation de paiement il y a
quelques mois le groupe Casino était au
bord de laasséation de paiement il
fallait trouver des repreneurs mais il
fallait assurer la jonction nous l'avons
fait en prenant à notre charge le
paiement des charges sociales et des
charges fiscales à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros qui ont été mis dans
une filuci et qui doivent être
remboursés par le repreneur nous avons
en deuxième lieu aidé à trouver un
repreneur il y en a eu je le rappelle
qu'un seul qui a pu mettre sur la table
le milliard d'euros nécessaire pour la
reprise maintenant il faut garantir
l'avenir du groupe et donc s'assurer
qu'avec le reste de la grande
distribution française l'ensemble des
salariés puisse trouver une solution je
suis donc en contact avec
l'intersyndical je suis évidemment en
contact avec avec le repreneur Daniel
kretinski et en contact avec l'ensemble
des distributeurs qui voudrai reprendre
une partie des activités du Groupe
Casino pour assurer la survie de
l'activité et la survie des magasins je
seraiis attentif une fois encore à trois
points essentiels le premier c'est
évidemment l'emploi garantir que dans
les offres de reprise qui pourrai être
faites par les uns ou par les autres
pour les hypers et pour les supermarchés
qui sont aujourd'hui des centres de
perte pour le groupe le ma maximum
d'emploi soit préservé la deuxième chose
c'est sur les centres logistiques il y a
13 centres logistiques quand il y a une
reprise il y a un grand risque que le
distributeur est déjà son centre
logistique donc ne le reprennent pas là
aussi je seraiis vigilant sur l'emploi
dans les centres logistiques enfin
évidemment première des préoccupations
le siège de Saint-Étienne il y a 1800
emplois je rappelle que sur ces 1800
emplois 12 sont consacrés aux hyper au
super nous veillerons aussi au maintien
du siège de Saint-Étienne la parole est
à notre collègue HERV renud pour le
groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse
également à monsieur le ministre Bruno
LEM sur la situation également de casino
voyez combien cette situation préoccupe
les élus du territoire préoccupe les
habitants et combien cette préoccupation
transcende effectivement l'éclivage
politique il il en il en va également
d'une question de de souveraineté
économique pour notre pays l'histoire de
casino et de Saint-Étienne sont
intimement liés le siège du groupe il
est installé depuis 125 ans geéofr
Guichard en est tout un symbole
actuellement nous assistons à un crash
économique en direct une stratégie
inadaptée à siphoner les comptes du
groupe qui présente une dette habissale
évaluer il est vrai après de 12
milliards d'euros comment d'ailleurs un
PDG a-t-il pu jongler avec les finances
du groupe tout en étant dans le même
temps l'actionnaire principal le
démantèlement a commencé il y a
maintenant plusieurs mois avec la vente
de marque à l'étranger puis en France
des ventes à la découpe hier goport dont
on connaît la suite Leader Price demain
peut-être Monoprix franc prix Vival
Naturalia ou C discount 300 hyper et
supermarchés sont actuellement sur la
Salette l'intersyndical à juste titre
est très inquiète et craint que dans la
foulée les entrepôts logistiques ne
puissent être maintenus les syndicats
ont alerté compte sur le soutien du
président de la République lui-même
qu'en est-il monsieur le ministre nous
sommes proche d'une casse sociale sans
précédent 50000 emplois en France 4000
rien que dans la Loire sont menacés
monsieur le ministre depuis les propos
que vous avez tenu en juillet dernier
les choses ont visiblement évolué
défavorablement le plan initial n'est
pas respecté vous avez reçu l'inters
syndicale effectivement ce matin
pouvez-vous apporter la garantie du
maintien du siège et des emplois à
Saint-Étienne nos habitants ne veulent
pas revivre le traumatisme d'un nouveau
Manu
France Merci pour vous répondre la
parole au ministre de l'Économie des
Finances Monsieur le Maire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous redis que je n'ai
qu'une seule priorité c'est le maintien
de l'emploi et la préservation de
l'emploi et à Saint-Étienne et dans les
hyper et les supermarché mais je pense
que vous avez décrit parfaitement la
situation il y a eu des erreurs de
positionnement stratégique de la part de
la direction de casino depuis des années
avec un positionnement sur des prix
élevés là où les concurrents faisaient
des prix bas et quand il y a une
inflation sur les produits alimentaires
bien évidemment cette stratégie
économique a mené le groupe droit dans
le mur et les chiffres de pertes que
vous avez donné sont les bons 50000
emplois qui du coup ont été menacés nous
avons garanti la reprise nous avons pris
à notre charge les dettes sociales et
les dettes fiscal et nous accompagnons
maintenant la reprise par d'autres
groupes de distribution je suis
convaincu que les possibilités de
reprise permettront de relancer
l'activité des upers des supers mais
également les centres de profit que sont
les Monoprix les franc prix les Spar les
petits magasins qui sont en
centrre-ville maintenant d're
préoccupation je le redis c'est le
centre de Saint-Étienne l'engagement que
j'ai pris c'est sur le maintien du siège
mais il y a des réalités économique et
je ne les ai jamais caché sur les 1800
personnes qui travaillent sur ce siège
12 travaillent dans les hyper et les
supermarchés 200 ont déjà été cédés au
groupe Intermarché d'autres vont être
cédés dans les mois qui viennent pour
garantir la pérennité de l'activité et
la pérennité de l'emploi l'engagement
que j'ai pris et qu'a pris le repreneur
Daniel kretinski c'est le maintien du
siège à Saint-Étienne je veillerai à ce
que cet engagement soit tenu merci la
parole est à notre collègue Alexandre wi
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur le S décembre à l'Élysée il
a été porté atteinte au principe de
séparation des Églises et de l'État un
ministre du culte en l'espèce le grand
Rabin de France a allumé la première
bougie d'anuka dans la salle des fêtes
du palais présidentiel en présence du
chef de l'État ceci est radicalement
contraire à la Constitution au principes
qui nous fonde au principe qui nous lit
et au fait que le Président de la
République en est le garant monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur ma question elle
est finalement assez simple dans l'Oise
il y a quelques jours nous avons rendu
hommage à Ferdinand Buisson nous avons
dit que le la religion libre dans l'état
libre c'était la règle qui nous sur
laquelle nous nous
retrouvions comment peut-on imaginer que
le Président de la République
aujourd'hui est commis un tel impère par
rapport aux règles de laïcité comment
peut-on aujourd'hui vous faire confiance
lorsque la première ministre depuis
Mayotte nous dit qu'il s'agit là
simplement d'un soutien à la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur on ne combat pas
l'anti on ne combat pas l'antisémitiste
avec des offices religieux pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
confirmer que il n'y aura pas de messe
de Noël à Matignon cette année qu'il n'y
aura pas de rupture du jeûe au printemps
au ministère de l'Intérieur pouvez-vous
nous dire que les palais de la
République ne ur on pas le lieu d'office
cultuel pouvez-vous tout simplement nous
dire que c'était un accident et non un
précédent je vous
remerci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur sénateur
si vous trouvez dans l'actualité
française comme très grande difficulté
pour nos concitoyens le fait que le
Président de la République ait reçu et
personnellement j'en suis fier le prix
par des rabins du monde entier de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme au nom de
l'engagement de la France je crains que
n'avons pas le même sens de
priorités c'est d'autant plus étonnant
au moment où nos compatriotes juifs et
vous le savez très bien connaissent 1800
actes et actions antisémites depuis le
1er janvier et quelque part monsieur
monsieur le
sénateur votre provocation qui consiste
à évoquer des messes à Matignon ou je ne
sais quel ou je ne sais quelle cérémonie
religieuse dans n'importe
quel dans n'importe quelle dans
n'importe quelle édifice public montre
sans doute que vous n'avez pas pris la
hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait pour nos
concitoyens Juifs nos compatriotes juifs
qui protège que protège la République
vous savez vous signé monsieur Bisson
mais chacun à sa gauche permettez-moi de
citer monsieur jores à propos de la loi
de séparation des aiguises et de
l'état la loi la loi laisse sa liberté à
tous les cultes la liberté de conscience
sera garantie et complète partout et
absolu la loi telle qu'elle est est
libérale juste sage c'est dommage que le
Parti socialiste s'éloigne encore de
jores quelques
secondes
nous sommes éloignés de personne ce
n'est pas parce que ce n'est pas votre
actualité monsieur monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur et on le comprend bien
que ce n'est pas une actualité pour les
Français c'est un principe fondateur de
la République et en ne le respectant pas
en n'admettant pas cette faute vous
tombez de marche en marche tous les
jours merci la parole est à notre
collègue François bonhomme pour le
groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre jeudi dernier à
l'invitation du président de la
République une cérémonie marquant le
début de la fête juif de ranuka s'est
déroulé dans la salle des fêtes de
l'Élysée à cette occasion le président
de la République a convié le grand Rabin
de France et de fait il a participé à
cette grande fête religieuse pourtant la
simple prudence et plus encore le rôle
qui est le sien comme protecteur de la
laïité aurait dû le dissuader de se
prêter à une telle cérémonie tant au
regard de son rôle
éminent de la au regard de la
Constitution regard du lieu emblématique
dans lequel s'est déroulé cette
cérémonie à caractère religieux alors
Monsieur le Ministre part partagez-vous
l'analyse selon laquelle le président de
la République a commis une erreur au
regard de la fonction qui est la sienne
et comment à l'avenir comptez-vous
combattre une t une telle atteinte à la
laïcité pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le sénateur
mais vous inquiétez pas chacun aura son
grand
homme monsieur le sénateur bonhomme
monsieur le Président mesames messieurs
les
sénateurs c'est étonnant que le groupe
qui soutenait alors le général Gaulle ne
sepposait pas qu'une
chapelle qu'une chapelle exista à
l'Élysée où le général avec sa famille
faisait et c'est bien normal faire son
office en pleine 5e République
pensez-vous monsieur le sénateur que
c'est ça qui touche notre pacte
républicain le fait que l'antisémitisme
soit mis en avant par des questions
d'actualité lorsque nous nous luttons
monsieur le
sénateur lorsque nous luttons
collectivement contre l'atteinte fait à
nos compatriotes juif pensez-vous que ce
sont les Juifs de France qui portent
atteinte et le grand Rabin qui ramène
une bougie d'wiitz puisqu'il s'agit de
ça monsieur le sénateur pensez-vous que
c'est ça la conception que vous avez des
attentes à les cité je pense que c'est
plutôt l'islam radical je pense que
c'est plutôt les attaques des
associations communautaristes pour
lequel le gouvernement a fait voter la
loi séparatisme fait fermer des mosquées
radicales attaque ici ou là des
commerces communautaires ne trouveit pas
des polémiques inutiles il n'y a pas eu
de cérémonie religieuse à l'Élysée il y
a eu un moment où le président de la
République a reçu un prix contre
l'antisémitisme il serait bon que nous
nous iniitionons contre le vrait
obscurantisme c'est le radicalisme
religieux c'est pas nos compatriotes
Juifs
bonhomme monsieur le ministre quand on
convoque jores ou de Gaul il faut avoir
les citations et l'esprit clair si si de
Gaul a effectivement installer à ses
frais une petite chapelle sur la cour
d'honneur donant sur la cour d'honneur
de l'Élysée c'était uniquement pour
célébrer les messes privées ça fait une
grosse différence enfin Monsieur le
Ministre et ça confirme votre répon
pense quelque peu unentortiller mais je
crois que c'est pas il s'agit pas
simplement d'une maladresse uneune bvue
une maladresse il s'agit surtout de de
considérer qu'il y a une certaine
confusion mentale qui a eu lieu vendredi
à l'Élysée que la célébration n'avait
pas sa place à l'Élysée et qu'en
méconnaissant le souci de neutralité
religieuse notamment dans le contexte de
tension que nous connaissons vous avez
offert là un prétexte fâcheux pour que
des communautés religieuses sans prévale
et s'y engouffre de même vous donner un
même motif parfois inespéré pour
certains pour nourrir un nouvel
antisémitisme auquel nous sommes
confrontés en accréditant l'idée selon
laquelle absurde selon laquelle la
communauté juive aurait été privilégiée
autrement dit c'est une peu la politique
de gribouille pour éviter d'être mouillé
vous êtes jeté à l'eau enfin dernier
élément sur la politique
communicationnelle du gouvernement on a
sorti la journée de la liicité on a
sorti le le dépliant de la licité le
référent de laicité une journée de la
laïcité et pourquoi pas un numéro vert
alors Monsieur le Ministre peut-être
communiquerez-vous tout tous ces objets
publicitaires au présid de la République
pour qu'il se
reprenne monsieur le Président ni messe
ni polémique dans ma question mais
simplement le constat depuis plusieurs
semaines de grandes intempéries dans les
territoires de France dans mon
département les Hautes Alpes 47 communes
ont demandé le classement en
connaissance de catastrophe naturell
suite aux intempéries des 15 derniers
jours plusieurs questions la première
madame la ministre pouvez-vous
m'indiquer où en est la reconnaissance
en catastrophe naturelle pour ces
communes deuxième question vous avez
annoncé lors de votre visite dans mon
département pour accompagner le malheur
de mes concitoyens et des élus locaux le
fait qu'il n'y aurait aucune aucun reste
à charge pour les collectivités impacté
par ces intempéries qu'en est-il 3è
question le ministre B a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises dans cet hémicycle la
perspective d'un décret qui viserait à
faciliter et à simplifier les conditions
de curage et d'entretien de nos réseaux
d'eau de canaux de rivières dans les
territoires de France qu'en est-il c'est
une attente profonde dans nos
territoires merci pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge des collectivités territoriales
madame fort merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Arnaud d'abord
merci de vous être excusé auprès de moi
de pas pouvoir m'accompagner lorsque je
me suis rendu sur les lieux auprès de
ces trois communes permettez-moi tout
d'abord de dire tout le soutien du
gouvernement aux élus et effectivement
vos collègues étaient présents et l'ont
vu mais aussi des départements
limitrophes j'ai tenu à me rendre
personnellement vous le savez je salue
l'engagement de nos service de secours
des agents de l'État des collectivités
mais aussi des entreprises qui sont
revenus tout simplement mettre le
torrent dans son lit dans la rivière
soyez assurés que la solidarité
nationale s'exprimera également
pleinement d'abord vous m'interrogez sur
les 37 dossiers oui ces 37 dossiers
communaux de demande de reconnaissance
de l'état de catastrofhes naturell ont
déjà constitué et obtenu un avis
favorable de la commission
interministérielle les autres dossiers
certains pourraient être en retard
Monsieur le Préfet a dit que pendant 48h
72h il accepterait que les dossiers
arrivent et donc on a mis un peu de
souplesse dans ces sollicitations il
convient d'aider financièrement les
communes en mobilisant l'aide de l'État
le soutien des conseil régionaux et
départementaux je salue à la fois le
président de votre département monsieur
le sénateur et le président de votre
région sud qui ont tout deux dit que
bien sûr il seraiit au côté de l'État au
côté des communes sinistré nous sommes
donc pleinement mobilisés avec le
ministre Gérald daranin sur ce sujet et
des points d'étape réguliers sont d'ors
et déjà prévus j'ai les portables
évidemment des maires principalement
concernés et j'ai déjà échangé avec eux
par ailleurs l'entretien des cours d'eau
est un élément important que vous avez
cité c'est votre troisème question dans
nos politiques de lutte contre les
inondations afin de simplifier ces
opérations vous l'avez cité Christophe
Béchu a transmis début novembre au
Conseil d'État un projet de décret
facilitant les opérations de curage
ponctuel des cours d'au visant à
restaurer leur fonctionnalité naturelle
ce décret pourra être publié à l'issue
des travaux du Conseil d'État et
vraisemblablement au tout début de
l'année 2024 je rappelle le travail de
fond engagé collectivement avec mes
collègues Bruno Le Maire et Christophe
sur
l'assurabilité des collectivités locales
nous avons effectivement mandaté une
mission sur ce sujet ensemble avec les
représentants les élus locaux les
assureurs nous allons nous assurer du
bon accompagnement de toutes les
collectivités qui subissent ces
catastrophes naturelles je vous remerci
oui madame la ministre je vous remercie
de ces précisions de votre visite et
vous avez à juste titre salué
l'engagement des collectivités locales
des élus mais aussi des professionnels
et également des citoyens qui ont fait
preuve de grande dignité à l'occasion de
ces événements 12 millions d'euros à la
seule charge du département des Hautes
Alpes 15 millions d'euros de travaux à
réaliser vous m'avez indiqué sans le
dire qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'autofinancement à la charge des
collectivités locales j'espère que vous
le confirmerez dans les prochaines
semaines et je vous en remercie je crois
qu'il y a un vrai sujet au-delà de mon
département c'est la gestion gmapi d'un
certain nombre de cours d'eau avec la
nécessité de travailler à mon aval à une
plus grande solidarité entre les
différents acteurs d'une part et d'autre
part faire en sorte que l'on puisse de
manière réglementaire davantage
intervenir et en prévention en
précaution sur ces cours d'eau pour
éviter demain d'avoir davantage encore
de catastrophes il faut sortir du dogme
on n'intervient pas sur un cours d'eau
en amont pour préserver la biodiversité
lorsqu'il y a une catastrophe il n'y a
plus de biodiversité tout part à la mer
ou tout part effectivement avec l'eau de
la montagne il est absolument nécessaire
de faire bouger les lignes en la matière
je vous remercie la parole est notre
collègue Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le
groupe les
républicains monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc après
merci après despe zdfe et zan que nous
connaissons toutes et tous désormais
c'est un nouvel acronyme auoland
cosmétique qui s'impose en France les
copes régionales que vous installez
chaque semaine dans chaque région en
dehors de tout contrôle parlementaire et
la méthode est toujours la même un haut
fonctionnaire décide seul à Paris et les
collectivités se débrouillent sans
compétences ni moyens supplémentaires en
lançant une nouvelle étape de
territorialisation écologique le 25
septembre dernier la première ministre
annoncé la méthode le secrétariat
général à la planification écologique
qui ne rend de compte à personne élabore
des slides désincarnés transmis aux
régions et cette façon de faire n'est ni
coopérative ni transparente puisqu'elles
se sont déjà engagées elles sontjà
engagées depuis et depuis longtemps dans
la transition écologique les régions ne
sont pas seules à agir les régions en
tout cas n'ont pas les marges de
manœuvre qu'on veut bien leur donner sur
les 40 leviers de décarbonation les 150
actions types les 160 questions oui ou
non à la seule de l'État qu'on leur
soumet les régions sont contraintes de
transcrire les décisions de l'État dans
des stratégies nationales sous les
trroits de surveillance des des préfets
et sans les élus très souvent
malheureusement c'est un contrôle de
conformité étatique qui nous ramène
peut-être au temps de la tutelle d'avant
1982 la loi vous oblige pourtant à
présenter tous les 5 ans une loi de
programmation énergétique servant de
base à la déclinaison territoriale nous
attendons toujours cette grande loi
monsieur le ministre est simple ma
question est simple comment pouvez-vous
être à la fois le ministre qui a accepté
avec nous pendant des mois et des mois
la territorialis duusan par exemple et
en même temps être celui d'une
planification écologique imposée aux
régions une fois passé le temps de la
communication des copes régionales quels
seront les moyens financiers que vous
envisagerez pour pour pour les conférer
à ces collectivités pour réussir la
transition
écologique pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique monsieur
Béchu monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Baptiste blanc j'ai
un défaut que je dois confesser
ici je ne vous réjouissez pas je je n'en
confesserai
qu'un j'ai passé 6 ans au Sénat et ça
m'a durablement déformé en étant
convaincu que non seulement cette
chambre est précieuse pour la République
mais d'autre part ce qu'on apprend et ce
qu'on dit ici dans le fait de travailler
avec les élus locaux est une des
manières de faire en sorte de réussir à
réformer ce pays dans la circulaire du
29 septembre dernier sur les cops
territoriales il est écrit à la fin du
premier paragraphe du haut de la page 3
que les parlementaires sont
systématiquement invité à l'ensemble de
ces COP territoriales et présentant
votre question j'ai vérifié que vous
aviez vous-même été destinataire de
l'invitation et ça a été le cas à la COP
territoriale de la région sud j'ai ce
matin en Bourgogne installé une de ces
COP et il est dommage que vous n'ayez
pas pu vous rendre à celle qui s'est
tenue un lundi à Marseille parce que
vous auriez pu mesurer que c'est
exactement l'inverse de ce que vous
venez de décrire
nous faisons très exactement l'inverse
nous sommes inflexibles sur une ambition
nous avons pris des engagements
climatiques collectivement y compris
avant ce gouvernement en disant que nous
devions baisser nos émissions et dans ce
contexte pour tenir cette ambition il y
a une méthode c'est la planification et
il y a un choix c'est de faire confiance
au territoire la première étape c'est
celle du diagnostic la photo de ce que
sont les émissions les leviers qui sont
disponibles c'était le cas ce matin avec
des dizaines de ma de la région
Bourgogne avec 400 participant à Dijon
c'était le cas il y a quelques jours en
ocitanie ce sera le cas dans quelques
jours en Auvergne ronalpe où je ne doute
pas qu'on aura l'occasion de parler
zânes à nouveau avec le président vquier
dans les 6 mois qui viennent département
par département et à l'échelle des
communes on va remonter les actions qui
sont déjà misise en œuvre et faire
ensuite en sorte que dans le cadre du
fond vert on puisse faire en sorte que
les crte deviennent des contrats de
réussite de la transition écologique et
qui bénéficient de financement parmi
lesquels une partie de ce qui a été voté
dans cet hémicycle sur le soutien au
territoire qui met en place des PC aet
voilà la méthode voilà l'explication
monsieur
blanc don tact monsieur le ministre
pourquoi avons-nous une impression de de
gos plan qui qui dit pas son nom il va
falloir vraiment veiller à cette
gouvernance et éviter cette écologie
PowerPoint à laquelle on assiste
sincèrement et tenir compte des actions
de décarbonation déjà conduites par les
collectivités du bloc communal et des
conseils
départementaux merci la parole est à
notre collègue pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicains merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je veux ici dans
notre hémiycle témoigner solennellement
de la détresse d'un grand nombre de
vignerons je suis moi-même trop souvent
exposé à cette souffrance sur mon
territoire le 25 novembre en Arbonne ils
étit 6000 viticulteurs d'Occitanie à
manifester dans le CAL monsieur le
ministre vous le savez seul un
accompagnement massif de l'État
permettra une sortie de crise
c'est pourquoi nous demandons un plan
Marchal pour la viticulture un plan
Marchal bien sûr mais à de détaches en
premier lieu les aides d'urg doiv servir
à sauver les exploitations confronté à
d'importantes difficultés de trésorerie
es doivent être justement calibr il faut
que les fonds soi débloqués rapidement
afin d'être réellement util et efficace
et qu'aucune aucune exploitationre sur
le côté une blanche doitêtre également
tre mise sur la table
ensuite le deuxème étage c'est la
construction d'un plan d'avenir pour la
filière autour de deux grands objectifs
d'une part permettre à toute une
génération de viticulteurs de sortir
dignement dignement de la profession
après une vie de travail d'autre part
encourager le renouvellement de
génération en facilitant l'installation
des Gunes
agriculteur face aux tensions qui existe
sur le marché il faudra recourir à de
l'arrachage de l'arrachage temporaire
certes mais aussi de l'arrachage social
correctement indamnisé
sécuriser les nouvelles générations
c'est également apporter des réponses au
défi climatiques avec l'adaptation des
pratiques des cépaches l'accès à la
ressources en eau et aussi l'enjeu de la
résilience à travers l'assurance récolte
sur ce point monsieur le ministre nous
attendons toujours que le gouvernement
engage les discussion pour une sortie de
la référence olympique monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous aujourd'hui
rassurer les hommes et les femmes qui
par leur savoir-faire font la fierté de
nos territoirees pouvez-vous le Rapp
porter des réponses d'abord sur un juste
calibrage des mesures d'urgence ensuite
sur un plan d'avenir pour la filière
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au porte-parole du gouvernement monsieur
Veron merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Denis BO alors
hélas je ne suis pas le ministre de
l'Agriculture néanmoins néanmoins j'ai
l'honneur j'ai l'honneur de partager une
passion avec vous monsieur le
sénateur je partage une passion avec
vous monsieur monsieur le sénateur la
passion pour le bon vin et la passion
pour le patrimoine culturel et pour le
patrimoine viticole qui en fait partie
je ne m connais pas Monsieur Nous ne m
connaissons pas évidemment les
difficultés rencontrées par la
profession des viiculteurs vous l'avez
dit les reprises d'exploitation agricole
faire face au désastres climatique le
mildu pour prolonger le débat que vous
avez eu la semaine dernière au Sénat
j'avais moi-même pu constater c'était
pas dans le Sud-Ouest mais d'autres
spages vous en voudrait pas ou des
agriculteurs commençaient à arracher des
spages traditionnels français pour
planter à la place T c Pag italien
portugais espagnol plus résistant à la
chaleur ce qui a évidemment aussi un
impact culturel patrimonial très fort
dans ce milieu des vticulteurs qui aime
la terre qui aime leur pays et qui
aiment le faire savoir Monsieur le
Sénateur vous posez une question
factuelle sur comment accompagner
comment l'État peut-il accompagner les
viticulteurs qui font face aux grandes
difficultés cette année notamment les
viticulteurs du Sud-Ouest hélas vous le
savez ça vous a été répondu par le
ministre Marc fen il n'y a pas de
dispositif aujourd'hui légal permettant
de mettre en place
un fond tel que vous le souhaitez
néanmoins je vous le rappelle volontiers
face à une situation économique
particulièrement dégradée dans certains
bassin de production le fond d'urgence
de 20 millions d'euros qui a été voté
dans le cadre du PLF et que le Sénat a
voté il y a peu va être déployé afin
d'accompagner les viticulteurs les plus
en difficulté de trésorerie et donc
notamment dans le sud-ouest par ailleurs
en lien avec la filière nous continuons
à expertiser des soutiens
complémentaires pour accompagner les
viticulteurs dans la crise qu'il
traversent et je veux rappeler
l'engagement fort du gouvernement en
faveur de la viticulture le gel en 2021
ça a été 572 millions d'euros de soutien
le gel en 2022 ça a été 17 millions
d'euros de soutien la grê en 2022 ça été
26 millions d'euros de soutien vous
voyez qu'à chaque fois l'état est
capable de se mobilisé pour soutenir la
viticulture cette année encore 200
millions d'euros pour un dispositif
exceptionnel de diciliation et le
ministre de l'Agriculture a par ailleurs
annoncé qu'un travail serait mené pour
la mise en place d'un dispositif de prêt
bonifié je vous remercie merci la parole
est à notre collègue Pascal Gruny pour
le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
la France voit ses petits commerces
mourir à petit feu pas un jour ne passe
sans que nous ne soyons sollicités par
des commerçants à bout de souffle qui ne
parviennent plus à se verser de salaire
et qui envisageent de baisser le rideau
en quelques années ils ont eu à subir la
crise sanitaire l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie les taxes comme la CFE un
pouvoir d'achat des Français en Bern et
la concurrence redoutable du commerce en
ligne beaucoup d'entre eux doivent
encore rembourser péniblement leurs PGE
ou leurs échéances sur SAF et comme si
cela ne suffisait pas vous avez
encouragé à la veille de Noël une
publicité de laadème mettant en scène
des dévendeurs pour inciter à la
déconsommation une nouvelle gifle pour
les 700000 commerces de proximité qui
font pourtant vivre plus de 3 millions
de Français et jouent un rôle essentiel
dans la vie sociale de nos territoires
alors que les élus locaux ne cessent de
tirer la sonnette d'alarme et vous ont
remis à plusieurs reprises des
propositions concrètes vous ne semblez
pas avoir pris conscience de la gravité
de la situation monsieur le ministre les
mesures cosmétiques ne suffisent plus
quelles mesures concrètes entendez-vous
prendre pour soutenir véritablement nos
commerces de proximité écrasé par la
conjoncture je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique la cohésion des territoires
vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
Gruny chaque jour nos concitoyens
nous-mêm nous sommes soumis à 20000
spots
publicitaires j'avoue je confesse et
j'assume que non pas avant les fêtes de
Noël pendant les 10 jours qui précèdent
le Black Friday 53 spots par jour sur
ces 20000 ont incité à se poser la
question de comment nous achetions et de
ce que nous
achetions en suggérant qu'on se demande
si parfois il fallait pas plutôt réparer
que d'acheter du neuf en suggérant
inister sur le reconditionner en
suggérant d'insister sur le recycler en
suggérant d'insister sur la location un
de ces
spots avec un dévendeur puisque c'était
le thème de cette campagne de l'Adème a
suscité une émotion en disant vous vous
trompé de cible pas forcément de message
mais de cible puisque on cible un
commerce physique et qu'aujourd'hui le
principal problème c'est pas les
commerces physiques ce sont les
platforme on est dans le paradoxe que
vous décrivez en 10 an en moyenne chacun
d'entre nous nous achetons 30 % de
vêtements de plus qui a 10 ans et
pourtant les enseignes physiques ferm
c'est bien la preuve que baisser la
consommation ou faire en sorte qu'on
aachète pas autant de vêtements ça ne
conduit pas à des fermetures la question
c'est quel type de vêtement à quel
endroit et en particulier la question de
la qualité la maladresse dans ce spot
c'était pas d'inciter à se poser la
question de savoir si on en a besoin
c'était de cibler un commerce physique
j'ai reçu
laacpme le medf et 20 fédérations
professionnelles au ministère qui se
sont déclarés satisfaites non seulement
de l'entretien mais de la manière dont
on allait dans les semaines qui viennent
imaginez sans doute une campagne qui
permettent de porter un message sur le
soutien à au made in France au fabriqués
à proximité au fabriqué en qualité au
réparable pour qu'on soit en capacité de
porter un double message qu'on doit à la
fois soutenir nos commerces et c'est ce
que j'ai fait dans ma vie d'élu local et
que je continue de m'efforcer de faire
et dans le même temps de faire attention
aussi aux ressources de la planète parce
qu'on a tous à perdre de ne se
préoccuper qu'une seule de ces deux
cibles madame
Gruny oui merci alors sur les dévendeurs
les dégâts sont faits il y a pas de pas
de souci continuez comme ça et ce sera
très bien moi ma question c'était quand
même le soutien au au commerce de de
proximité particulièrement ils auraient
besoin d'un manager de ville il faut
aider les les communes justement à
offrir ça aux commerçants parce que ils
ont du mal à se battre contre le
e-commerce et puis aussi peut-être
baisser la TVA réfléchir à à à les aider
aussi de ce côté-là pour éviter les
concurrences desloyales en tout cas
vraiment he je vous invite monsieur le
ministre à venir faire vos courses
dimanche parce que eux ils travaillent
donc vous viendrez avec moi nous allons
faire nos courses à Saint-Quentin et
vous verrez les messages des des
commerçants et et je vous assure que moi
j'y vais toutes les semaines et que ils
en ont assez assez des taxes et qu'il
faut les aider alors les promesses bien
entendu sont aller dans votre bureau
mais nous ce qu'on veut ce sont des
actes et c'est ce qu'on compte suivre
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Franck mononville pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires elle porte sur le
transfert de la compétence haut et
assaainissement des commune aux
intercommunalités ce transfert
obligatoire initialement prévu par la
loi nôre au 1er janvier 2020 a été
reporté au 1er janvier 2026 par la loi
du 3 août 2018 et pour cause ce
transfert suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude
chez les élus locaux notamment dans sa
mise en œuvre depuis le Sénat n'a eu de
cesse de se mobiliser pour le rappeler
dernière initiative en dat de notre
assemblée la proposition loi porté par
notre collègue Jean iverrou qui
consacrait une approche différenciée de
la gestion de cette
compétence adopté à une large majorité
le 16 mars dernier le texte n'a pour
l'heure pas prospéré mais le 30 mars
dernier le président de la République en
déplacement dans les Hautes Alpes a
explicitement ouvert la voie à une
évolution notable dans ces conditions
monsieur le ministre alors que la date
de transfert au 1er janvier 2026
approche à grand pas où en sommes-nous
peut-on envisager que cette compétence
ne soit pas systématiquement transférée
aux intercommunités peut-on envisager un
traitement différencier adapté aux
réalités territoriales sans revenir sur
une gestion purement communale
entendez-vous faire évoluer le cadre du
transfer et permettre aux communes de
s'organiser elles-même en en bas
s'inversant autour des aires
d'alimentation par le biais de
structures syndical
notamment pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la cohésion des
[Applaudissements]
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Monville à la fin
de ces questions au Gouvernement
j'aurais donc une invitation à aller
faire le marché de Saint-Quentin à
retourner au côté des élus locaux dansf
je suis un peu déçu que vous ne m'ayez
pas proposé d'aller à steinville pour
qu'on puisse échanger ensemble sur votre
territoire vous avez raison la ppll rou
qui a été voté dans cette assemblée n'a
pour le moment pas trouvé de relais
auprès de l'Assemblée nationale à vrai
dire le texte a bien été repris par un
groupe il a été inscrit dans une niche
parlementaire mais dans cette niche
parlementaire il y avait tellement de
textte que la priorité a donneré un
autre et un en particulier visant à
abroger la réforme des retraites qui a
fini par tellement occuper l'Assemblée
nationale ce jour-là que le texte n'a
pas pu être évoqué et pourtant cette PPL
contient deux dimensions importantes une
que vous n'avez pas évoqué mais que je
rappelle parce que je pense qu'elle est
partagée sur tous les banc ici et très
largement à l'extérieur qui est le fait
de permettre à nouveau au département de
pouvoir financer et sécuriser les
travaux qui concernent les communes cet
engagement la première ministre a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler en marge du
congrès de laadf au président sovadet
pour dire à quel point nous soutenions
ce point qui est le point 35 de du plan
haut présenté à Savine leLac le 30 mars
dernier la deuxième dimension dont vous
parlez je vois le président Arnaud qui
s'en souvient parfaitement c'est que ce
jour-là à Savine lac le président de la
République a dit qu'il fallait sans
doute ne pas imaginer qu'un jardin à la
française était le meilleur moyen de
gérer la compét ha partout dans notre
pays et que compte tenu de la taille
moyenne d'un certain nombre
d'intercommunalité il fallait imaginer
un dispositif qui tienne compte de deux
impératif j'insiste et Dominique fort à
laquelle je rends hommage parce queelle
a eu à la fois l'occasion de s'investir
sur le texte jusqu'à maintenant et de
elle va la vocation à continuer à le
faire a pu le préciser
1 nous ne pouvons pas retourner vers un
système ou conserver un système de
commune
isolé je le dis parce que dans ce
contexte quand on superpose la réalité
des communes en rupture d'eau et les
taux de fuite on s'aperçoit que c'est
une fausse bonne idée de obliger à
l'intercommunalité en n'acceptant pas
qu'on puisse avoir entre les deux un
système ou de syndicat ou de coopération
c'est une souplesse que nous devons
trouver et à laquelle en 2024 nous
trouverons le déboucher le véhicule
législatif pour assurer la suite de la
PPL
rou monsieur men
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse il existe vous l'avez dit donc
du temps gouvernemental pour le mettre à
l'ordre du jour de de l'Assemblée
nationale moi je voudrais seulement
peut-être vous dire que permettez-moi
donc d'évoquer que malheureusement dans
notre pays il y a suffisamment de
réformes à conduire de dysfonctionnement
dans nos politiques publiques il faut
pas désorganiser ce qui est organisé sur
les territoires donc il faut de la
souplesse et permettre je crois que
c'est important une délégation direct
des communes aux structures de leur
choix sans systématiquement des sub
délégations par les
EPCI
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
les prochaines auront lieu le mercredi
20 décembre je vais suspendre la séance
merci madame la Première ministre merci
mesdames et messieurs les ministres elle
sera reprise à
16h35 pour les examen de la proposition
de loi visant à favoriser le réemploi
des véhicules au service des mobilités
durabl et solidaires sur les territoires
la séance est
suspendue